one of the major major keys we found the
first
high-performing habit is i believe that
potential unexpressed turns to pain
remember that day that you sat there and
were furious and pissed off all day over
something that you couldn't control
why'd you waste that day wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the success
routines that you
must follow enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have a good morning ritual with
oprah winfrey
every morning i prepare myself for the
day so i listen to some form
of either a spiritual song
or i read some kind of spiritual passage
i do i read something called the bowl of
saki which is written by a
a sufi master or i'll read a daily word
and then i
i meditate and i do a gratitude
um journal and whether i'm doing it
electronically or whether i'm you know
writing in my little journal that i can
i don't carry the journal around
if i'm going to be on longest vacations
because once i left a journal in a hotel
and god only knows what you could sell
that for so i don't do that
but i i keep uh some form of spiritual
practice
where i remind myself daily
of where i've come from rule number two
work on your soul with robin charma
i believe that potential unexpressed
turns to pain and
when we are born we're born as children
into awe and wonder adults are nothing
more than deteriorated children
but as we leave the perfection of
childhood where we're intimate
with our gifts and our talents and on
wonder
our parents doing their best say you
want to be an astronaut
be practical then we go to school we say
i want to be a rock star and i want to
be an actor and
i want to be jay shetty when i grow up
and they say oh no no he's a different
kind of
cut from a different cloth than you and
we
we get seduced by the beliefs of the
people around us and we go from this on
wonder and intimacy with
our glory our primal glory that's that's
just the human condition
and we start to forget who we truly are
and
as our dreams start to fall apart and as
we lose that connection with our best
selves and as we get sad
and disappointed and as we failed that's
just part of life
a lot of us shut down and we don't know
how to process through that pain
so we we repress it and so the great
sports superstars or the billionaires i
work with or
the you know companies like starbucks
fedex nike ibm when i work with their
leadership teams
what i do is i help them move through
that well
of blockage within themselves because
in the book there's a very disruptive
model
and it's called the four interior
empires and just really quickly so many
people are talking about mindset would
you agree
absolutely everything is mindset if you
just
dial in your mindset you're going to go
out there and you're going to change the
world well here's here's
what that model is about i i think
mindset is only 25
of the personal mastery equation yep and
here's why
it's very important to have a great
mindset that's your psychology you want
to wire in the beliefs of world class no
question but a great psychology
with a broken heart or a heart full of
pain if you haven't forgiven
the unforgiven if you're stuck in the
past
you can read the books and go to the
courses and get a great mindset you're
all on fire
but you sabotage yourself because your
emotional life is toxic
so it's not just mindset there's a
second word i'm introducing which is
it's going to transform people it's
heart set
but it's not only purifying your heart
set you want to
calibrate your mindset purify your heart
set
and then it's this other word i'm
introducing healthset that's the third
interior empire
because if you want to change the world
don't die
right you know yes so that one of the
keys to legendary is longevity
and there's a lot of the book on how to
how the best in the world the great
geniuses manage their vitality so they
were like in their 90s still rocking
their craft
so it's mindset hearts set health set
which is your physical life
and here's a key that i think will
resonate with you it's the fourth
interior empire is your
soul set yes now some of your listeners
from across the planet will go well i'm
a business builder or i want
creativity productivity why are we
talking about soul so well
if your ego is running the day you're
never going to go out there and change
the world
you know a bad day for the ego is an
awesome day for the soul
so working on your soul sets so you are
a titan of humanity and you're
intimate with your highest nature and
you're wiring in the great values and
you're living for a cause that's bigger
than yourself
that's what allows you to go out in the
world and move through failures
and really own your domain so those four
interior empires
once you work on those you go out in the
world
and automatically everything you touch
is golden
because our outer success is always a
function of who we
are on the inside rule number three
define the feeling that you are
after with brendan burchard one of the
major major keys we found
the first high-performing habit is seek
clarity
and what we found is one of the
practices that high performers do
is they define the feeling they're after
and so when we
had to explain that and later talk about
it in the energy chapter
we had to differentiate between feelings
and emotions and they are different
emotions tend to be
they're the same like we have they're
physical they're almost
always automatic even though when the
brain is creating associations there's
also happen
for us it's kind of emotion comes up
yeah you're watching a movie and you're
just sad and you're like oh my gosh you
know i'm crying
you didn't even have the tissues right
you're just like rock you know
but feelings are usually interpretations
that we make
of what that emotion was and how it
sticks and the meaning we give it to it
yeah and the example i used
you know i like to give and i don't
remember if it's in the book or not
honestly because here's what's happened
this book is 400 pages it was 1481 when
i finished
baby you edited it down yes and it was
1481 good
complete like it was like awesome yes
but i was like that's going to freak
people out so we're publishing a bunch
in academic journals later and then
stripped it down to 400 pages so it's
more readable and fun and orientable so
i can't remember if this one actually
made it in there but
um the example i like to give is if you
and i go to
a haunted house yeah which i love i love
them i love them and they scare me the
crap but if
you and i walk around you know you walk
around on the walls in a haunted house
come jumps out at you yeah you and i are
both going to jump yes
we are emotionally going to experience
fright
immediately it's going to be there right
but i might be
freaked out for the next five minutes
and you might be laughing
why it's the meaning and the feeling
that we've defined it as
that's fine for everybody here's the
issue that people have and you have to
be careful
about when we start talking about energy
because emotional energy is real
yes and that is look if at six like
we we go to the haunted house at you
know 5 p.m in the afternoon
if at 9 pm now you're in your house
you're alone but you're completely safe
and you still
feel scared that's not the haunted
house's problem
that is the way that you are defining
and working through your own emotions
you had the emotion of terror and fear
and you're still
experiencing that feeling that's a
mental job
not an emotional job so your job is to
go wow
i'm at my house i've lived here for 10
years i've never been threatened this
house this is a safe place
i gotta redefine the feeling i wanna
experience
and i work with one an olympic sprinter
gold medalist olympic sprinter
as a client and this person's huge
breakthrough
in getting better and going from
literally uh
one olympics before not meddling at all
to now gold i said what made like what
was the thing
yeah and one of the things they said to
me was i
learned to define the feeling and i said
what do you mean by that
and he basically said you know if if
if there's a bunch of us at the starting
box and we're all in perfect poise in
perfect condition
the one to bet on is the one that says
this is the way i want to feel in this
race right now i know my emotions are
going crazy like my heart's beating i
can hear
everybody i'm waiting for that shot
blast i i can see my goal
i know how important this is and all
these um like their emotions are there
yeah
but that person is defining the feeling
i'm going
to feel centered now i'm going to get
myself in the zone now
even though the anxiety is the emotion
of anxiety is there for all
olympic level com competitors all of
them but they define that
feat that emotion as a feeling that
helps give them a performance edge
and i think that's important too you
know bruce springsteen says if he's ever
backstage and doesn't feel
like nerves he's gonna hang it up yeah
but that's anxiety he's just defining it
differently all right my friend
evan carmichael's book listen humans are
built to serve
some people are built to serve the world
others
want to serve the 25 people closest to
them but in either case humans are built
to serve so if you're not happy right
now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
rule number four develop a good evening
routine with mel robbins
my night routine is very simple complete
the day and leave
no tasks that i have to finish in the
morning it's that
that's it and so it's not necessarily
that i have a specific order
but there are particular things that i
do number one totally set up the kids
so that means pack their lunches it
means get the backpacks ready if it's
school season and get them by the door
it means if there's any forms that need
to be filled out or printed or anything
else if they are printed they are ready
to go so kids are
handled second thing i want the kitchen
clean
i don't ever want to wake up in the
morning and walk in there and see
crap that i have to do i don't want
dishes in the sink i don't want
things on the counter and so i make sure
that the kitchen is clean
that the counters are cleared off and
that
there is no nothing i need to do in the
kitchen because it will distract me in
the morning i will feel
guilt i will feel obligated to get that
done
third thing that i do is i tend to set
out the
stuff for breakfast and the reason why i
do that
is because my kids will wake up at
various times
and so if i've got that thing set up
i've just bought myself a couple more
minutes of quiet in the morning
before the parade of children come
running down the stairs
starving and wanting breakfast the other
thing that i do is i go to my computer
and i print out the day
calendar for the day ahead
and then i take that printout and i take
my
notebook that has all of my travel and
kind of everything that's laid out for
the the business that i run and my
speaking schedule and stuff related to
the kids and i move it all to the
kitchen
now why am i doing this i'm doing this
so that when i
leave my bedroom in the morning and i
walk into the kitchen to have 30 minutes
of quiet time for myself
to get focused to plan my priorities
everything's set
it's all been handled there's no
thinking involved it's amazing
then once that's all handled i turn off
all the lights
i lock the front door when i walk into
my bedroom the very first thing that i
do
i set my alarm and then i plug my phone
in
in my closet that is the single most
important
aspect of my evening routine rule number
five learn
more with lewis howes i wish someone had
told me
to master more skills like become a
master
of your curiosity so i was mastering my
sports
but i wasn't mastering necessarily
relationship skills
early on and i wish i would have learned
more about communication
more about speaking in front of others
more about
articulating my idea and packaging it
and delivering it
to peers friends teammates whatever it
may be
learning communication i think that is
one of the most important skills in any
business getting any job
is to be able to deliver our message or
or our ideas in such a way that
it moves other people to action whether
that action is to
hire you to take your advice and use it
to
enroll people in your vision whatever it
may be
learning to communicate and it took me
until i was about 25
when i started to
take public speaking class because i saw
the value and the importance of
communicating your ideas and your
message and if you want to generate any
type of results
and get people behind anything you're up
to you need to learn how to
communicate what that is to them and get
them to take action on it
otherwise it's gonna be hard to get your
ideas out there or get people to buy
into who you
are and how you can support their
company if you're looking for a job
and rule number six the last one before
a very special bonus clip
is stop wasting your days with dean
graziosi
i hear this all the time and talk about
it all the time but it hits me in
different moments in my life
at the end of our life man we are going
to look back and wish we didn't get
mad at one thing or let things bug us or
worry about if someone took advantage of
us we got this life is going so damn
fast
and maybe that's because of the age of
that now i see how quick it's going i'm
going to be 50 this year that
when i'm recording this and i'm like wow
how did i get the 50. it went like that
so i got another 50 years left you know
it's like and that's if
you know if everything goes right and
man
what i what if i look back in my life
and i was at the end of it and i looked
back and said
i remember that day that you sat there
and were furious and pissed off all day
over something that you couldn't control
why'd you waste that day so i want to
ask you
why are you wasting any days especially
on things
people probably have taken advantage of
people probably hurt you in the past
but if you want the millionaire success
habits to go to another level the same
habits that'll
bring your joy abundance happiness
wealth prosperity
all together let it go let it go
you might never get the apology you
might never get i'm sorry you may never
get the money back
you may never get what you deserve
but that's okay because it'll come
someplace else remember karma it's not
about getting back from what you gave
just give everywhere and all of a sudden
someone taps you on the shoulder
and behind you without you even know it
was coming come becomes the perfect
relationship comes the perfect business
partnership
comes the money comes the company and uh
the more we can remember that the more
we can practice
it on a regular basis the more success
you'll have in your life
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your specific plan of action
for the next
week when you just watch a video and get
motivated by it you have a 35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated and then create
a specific plan of action you have a 91
chance of following through that's what
we do here believe nation we get
motivated but then we do
something about it and when you commit
to other people you increase your
chances
even further of following through so
what was your biggest takeaway from this
video
and then what is your plan of action
around for this week
put it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate
you as time has gone on i've become less
and less a fan
of goal setting and i love the idea of
quarterly goals
over annual goals over a decade long
goals
because the timeline is shorter and why
i'm less a fan of goal setting is
because
the more you're actually growing the
less
likely you're actually able to predict
where you're going to be
so i really hate 10-year goals
five-year goals 10-year goals if you
think about where you were
five years ago think about who you were
five years ago five years ago
look at the calendar five years ago from
today in the past who are you
you think that person could predict
where you would be
ten years ago 10 years ago i just
started my youtube channel
i had a couple videos up 10 years ago i
said i'd never want to write a book
10 years ago i wouldn't imagine that i'd
be here every year
making videos for youtube channel with
300 million views
in puerto rico because brendan burchard
invited me to his mastermind group
to speak on stage in front of all these
successful entrepreneurs
i wouldn't have predicted that like with
with zero accuracy
and same thing for you 10 years ago you
had no idea that you'd be here not if
you're growing
and this is the big caveat not if you're
growing like if you can predict
with accuracy where you're going to be
in 10 years
you can hit it but it's just way small
compared to what you could have done and
it means that you haven't grown in the
past decade
and so that's my main beef against goals
and
and having shorter goals having
numericals can be great
can be great like i want to get 10
million subscribers on my main youtube
channel
that's a good goal but if i set that as
my 10-year goal and that's the only
thing i'm gonna do
then it's wrong because probably in
three years i should jump off and
do something else right i've been
fortunate that
i've been doing youtube for 10 years i i
still love it it's still amazing but
chances are your 10 year plans you
should jump up in year two and go
through something else because that
thing is actually better for you
because you've grown as a person so at
least that's great
the advice that instead of annual goals
set it down to quarterly goals because
goals are still
helpful they're so good to kind of track
your progress to know that
this video did better than that video
that this customer brought in more money
than this customer that
are you doing enough action to go and
get the business that you want
those are great but as a macro
thing that's leading your decisions i
think the longer you stretch it out
the worse it actually is
no matter how good we are we can still
be better
you can always be better people like me
i was born in a very poor family
i never got a great education whatever
you focus on
whatever gets your attention gets
results